[Musique]
trois millions de personnes sont
directement intéressés par la propreté
de la capitale 3 millions de parisiens
qui avec l'esprit critique et caustique
qui les caractérise voit très bien les
lacunes dénonce les fautes des autres se
moquent même parfois de ceux qui
cherchent des remèdes et garde des
guerres en ce qui concerne leurs propres
manquements aux règlements en vigueur et
aux préceptes d'hygiène faire de paris
une ville toujours propres plus
accueillante du prestigieuse noble
ambition mais quelle tâche immense
car comme toutes les grandes villes
paris séquelles journellement heure par
heure minute par minute les atteintes
les plus directs à sa santé à saboter la
volonté du législateur montre par ce
décret c'est arrêter ces ordonnances
combien est grand sens aussi détenir
paris propre de l'art en souriant et
fleuri l'opération spectaculaire de
ravalement des édifices un rendu à paris
un visage renouveler 400 entreprises
employant mille ouvriers occupés en
permanence à la toilette de 800
immeubles les dépenses des particuliers
dans ses campagnes peuvent être estimés
à plusieurs centaines de milliards
d'anciens francs
les tarés lover les monuments publics à
sa charge mais que l'on ne s'y méprenne
pas si c'est là un tribut au souci
d'esthétique d'une des plus belles
capitales du monde la plus belle 10 des
étrangers ce n'est aussi au respect de
l'hygiène et la sauvegarde du patrimoine
immobilier
les campagnes de propreté entreprises au
bois de boulogne font de cet ensemble un
des plus magnifiques qui soit mais qu'en
pensent les parisiens les étrangers qui
visitent notre vie parce que paris est
une ville propre
oui les wii
non ils sont pas propres
mais non tout bateau pas du tout à tout
on veut séparer voyons c'est naturel ça
mais je pense qu'il ya encore des
progrès à faire
très certainement mais après ethernet
qu'il y à déjà les progrès le fuit
depuis le pic quelques temps et que
reprochez-vous je reproche que le saiss
et thomas sont pas toujours à la hauteur
de leur tâche et notamment dans la
proche banlieue de paris
je pense que paris est propre oui je
trouve paraît très propre et le suédois
oui je suis très droit et que
trouvez-vous de particuliers dans la
propreté de paris
ah oui c'est que chaque matin ch je vois
les lots qui court dans les rues
d'angers
un ruisseau le côté pour muntari la plus
belles baies du monde
très propre je m'insurge je reviens des
états unis sur sa très très proches
très moyennement
vous savez on boit beaucoup de quartiers
à ces salles quand même à laisse un peu
à désirer
d'abord dans cette fois rien c'est pas
très propre en vérité je pense pas que
ce que vous reprochez les gens là sont
montrés négligents et laisse facilement
entraîner des papiers des balances des
mégots n'importe où ma foi alors
pourquoi t de fruits il y a un peu de
négligence de dans le public
sinon ce serait une huile vraiment froid
tous les matins dès 6 heures les
voitures d'enlèvement des ordures
commence la récolte découvert c'est près
d'un million de tonnes qui est
annuellement enlevé mais paris ne s'est
pas fait en un jour et l'organisation
des services de voirie non plus c'est
par un arrêté du 16 janvier 1884 que
monsieur eugène poubelle préfet de la
seine institua les boîtes à ordures
ménagères cette mesure provoque à plus
de mécontentement que de plaisir car
elle supprimait la modeste industrie des
4000 chiffonniers de la capitale il
faisait partie de la physionomie de
paris et le système des boîtes les
ruminants dès 1861
il s'était formé un projet sous le titre
compagnie de nettoyage des rues de paris
une société qui avait pour but
l'enlèvement en poste des ordures de
paris entre 4 et 6 heures du matin cette
compagnie voulait établir quatre grands
dépôts situés aux quatre coins cardinaux
en dehors des fortifications où chaque
jour deux méthodes transporter tous les
détritus sont recueillis dans les rues
de la capitale et enfermés dans des
caisses dont la compagnie faisait
connaître les dimensions ce projet que
repris monsieur poubelle en devenant
ainsi le contrefacteur
si les chiffonniers date de toujours le
problème des ordures ménagères ne date
pas d'hier non au 12e siècle les oies
les lapins les canards et les ports
patauger autour des tas d'ordures dans
les rues au 14e siècle
philippe auguste fait pavé 4 rue
principale et ordonne de tuer les ports
qui errent sans mettre sur les berges
des chemins au xviie siècle le roi
accorde à des entrepreneurs le soin de
nettoyer paris mais la formule trop
nerveuse et bientôt abandonnée
en 1695 5772 long terme se balancent
dans les 912 rude pas
18e siècle traversé le bourg y ait des
rues malodorantes de la capitale les
choses malizé est souvent délicate
daumier un siècle plus tard peut
reprendre le même sujet et puis il y eut
haussmann et avec lui le paris moderne
nato disparaissent certaines venelles
plus en ses pittoresques ou eugène sue
se ravivent rodolphe frère de marie ève
chouinard tandis que victor hugo il
retrouvera l'image de la cour des
miracles en 1910 paris évident dès les
égouts débordent élan jettent les
ordures du haut du viaduc d'auteuil
quatre usines à sueur l'incinération des
déchets de la région parisienne
romainville ivry saint-ouen et issy les
moulineaux lusine d'issy les moulineaux
et la puissante et la plus moderne du
monde avec ses quatre jours elle peut
incinérés 19 tonnes à l'heure
l'incinération donne lieu à une
récupération de l'énergie calorifique
sous forme de production de vapeur et
d'énergie électrique pour le chauffage
urbain
en 1966 le tonnage total évacuées a été
de 1 million 600 mille tonnes et lusine
d'issy les moulineaux a incinéré à elles
seules 480 2500 tonnes d'ordures
ménagères
mais malgré la vigilance des services
certains déchets ménagers échoppes
l'enlèvement et à la destruction
il revient à nos créateurs l'autre
souffre de pollution et de déprédations
le s'est réduit vous êtes directeur une
importante entreprise de dératisation
vous travaillez souvent pour des
municipalités de la région parisienne
pourquoi ont-elles retour à vous
l'aluminerie pas été de la région
parisienne ont recours à nous du reste
comme les municipalités l'ensemble de la
france avec lesquelles nous travaillons
parce qu'ils ont estimé qu'il était plus
judicieux de faire appel à un organisme
privé pour traiter leur ville que de
constituer des équipes spéciales
municipal dont l'emploi ne serait pas
qu'on s'en va en toute l'année nous
savons que le rat est un animal
particulièrement intelligent et que
quand il voyait ses congénères mourir
brutalement il arrivait à détecter
l'odeur du toxique à effet brouilleurs
son confrère et après ça ils se soient
laissé mourir de faim plutôt que de
toucher un apport carré laisser
subsister à peu près la même odeur que
celle qui avait testé sur le cadavre et
on estime également que la population
bio in en france consomme ou détériore
temps il faut pas oublier que la
consommation est une chose mais qui est
presque moins importante ce ski est
détériorée par laurent qui a besoin de
ronger une façon permanente pour suis et
les dents et les dégradations qui sont
faites dans l'ensemble de la france
correspond à la botte presse qu'il faut
bonne nourriture pour une ville comme
paris pendant un an
est ce qu'on aura
même des ventes on voulait des rats et
des réglages
oui les clientes les femmes petit loto
écrit est ce que c'est la marge qu'ils
ont des préférences et ce qu'ils ont là
je crois qu'ils sont surtout portés à
manger du belon déloyale et les melons
et laureline la scène énormément parce
qu'on les voir courir la journée on les
voit courir la nuit
[Musique]
la situation varie d'un pavillon à
l'autre et l'on peut voir que les avis
sont souvent contradictoires
monsieur mailly vous êtes rapporteur de
la pop paris
y at il un problème des rats à paris
bien sûr il y a un problème des rats à
paris comme dans toutes les grandes
villes et à paris nous n'avons
malheureusement aucune machine
électronique qui puisse nous permettre
de dénombrer le nombre de rats mais je
crois que l'on peut facilement les
évalué à près de 4 millions
car chaque parisien nourrisson rats les
halles effectivement nous pose un
problème car nous nous trouvons sur un
terrain où depuis près de sept siècles
de nairas trouve une base permanente
tous les jours de nourriture
que vont devenir ces rats lorsque les
halles vont être transférés aux mains
jce la fin de l'année je pense que privé
de cette nourriture ils vont
certainement aller dans les quartiers
limitrophes par exemple le palais royal
peut-être même l'hôtel de ville pour
chercher à se nourrir
quels sont les moyens de lutte actuelles
à l'heure actuelle à paris nous n'avons
pas de gros moyens
le laboratoire duras existe il est
vous avez à peu près douze personnes qui
sont là pour conseiller le parisien mais
c'est le parisien lui même qui doit
lutter contre les rats contre cet
envahisseur en essayant de dératiser
comme à l'heure actuelle nous sommes en
pas de dératisation vous le savez
jusqu'au 25 mai et pour cela il faut
qu'il soit propre
il faut prendre toutes les précautions
nécessaires pour éviter de laisser de la
nourriture aux rats il ne se laisse pas
attraper facilement ils ne se laissent
pas empoisonner facilement on a employé
différents produits de dératisation
comme par exemple la strychnine et
maintenant c'est périmé n'est ce pas je
crois qu'il faut que nous donnions aux
principes de l'anticoagulant qui lui
permet de s'empoisonner dans les deux
trois jours qui lui fait une hémorragie
qui lui donne une hémorragie interne et
je crois que c'est à l'heure actuelle
c'est le meilleur moyen l'emploi des
anticoagulants dans les locaux du
laboratoire de la rue du faubourg saint
denis
madame core ulv ce responsable du
laboratoire des épidémies et du rhin de
la préfecture de police répond à nos
questions
la destruction des halles on se donne un
problème des rares elle en impose et un
certainement étant donné que les
pavillons des allemands d'être transféré
à régis à ce moment là les mandataires
qui effectuent eux-mêmes pour leur
compte la dératisation à l'heure
actuelle ne la ferons plus c'est en cela
que le problème s'est posé mais nous
l'avons prévu un schéma l'avancé déjà
depuis plusieurs mois nous avons fait
une enquête dans la périphérie des
halles 12/100 immeubles ont été visités
et ont été des rats tease et quand il y
avait des traces dans ces immeubles de
l'existence de rares et lorsque les
pavillons seront transférées à rungis il
suffira étant bien entendu prévenues à
l'avancé que notre service substitut sur
place aux mandataires et effectue alors
une dératisation permane
et dans ce cas il n'y aura pas de
problème particulier
quels sont nos moyens de lutte la plus
efficace berne a plusieurs il y a ce que
je peux appeler la lutte défensive qui
est une prévention et c2 beaucoup la
plus importante est alors en second lieu
il ya la lutte offensive qui est la
dératisation comprenant tic certains
préventive et bien c'est lui et plus de
préventif je vous disais c'est la plus
importante
elles concernent d'une part les
propriétaires d'immeubles où les gérants
d'immeubles et elle concerne d'autre
part les particuliers quelles sont les
précautions à prendre et bien en ce qui
concerne les propriétaires d'immeubles
ce qu'il faut c'est cuisine même soit
venu en bon état qu'il n'y ait pas de
détérioration notamment au niveau des
canalisations d'égouts qu'il n'y ait pas
de trou même dans les murs dans le bas
des portes des caves
en un mot il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
d'orifices par où les rats puissent
pénétrer dans les immeubles
ceci s'est déjà capital deuxièmement en
ce qui concerne les particuliers eux
mêmes et bien ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
d'abord qu'il ne faut pas nourrir les
rats car si les rats reste 48 heures
sans manger une humeur mais par contre
ils sont voraces et 10 carats a fait
manger jusqu'au tiers de son poids par
jour
mais si on ne les nourrit pas eh bien
les rats ne se met pas en place
[Musique]